ok let's go down the rabbit hole little
bit okay so I'll give you this question
let's consider a totally separate idea
let's take the square root of what was
that actually came up with something
yeah let's consider this okay
let's solve this shall we what would you
do to start solving this I would square
both sides right natural thing to do x /
-3 and that'll be x squared on 4 right
okay
but you were already because you've sort
of been tipped off by this right you're
already a little suspicious of squaring
both sides so what should I do before I
progress any further what should I take
note of from my first line here first
layer the card good there's some
restrictions on this domain right this
theme is telling us things before we
start mucking around with it that X
certainly cannot be so for instance
you've got a square root there okay so
that means that things underneath square
roots they have to be positive so you
would say well x squared minus 3 has to
be greater than zero right so X square
has got to be greater than 3 so do you
think about that X Squared's no your
interest x squared looks like this and
three is like across there so I can go
less than root 3 or X is greater than 3
is that a side of the trick is that okay
does that make sense
oh sorry any quality is okay right
because I can have it equal to zero you
shadows have that so far all right now
let's just keep this in mind and let's
start solving keeping that domain
restriction what do I do
suggestion multiply three we get rid of
the fractions so I get 4x squared minus
12 is an x squared
now what that's a - okay divide through
so I have two solutions namely plus or
minus two okay now does this check out
with the domain restrictions we said
before which okay right because this is
my minus one point seven and this is
minus 2 is less than one lens one
determine and that's positive one point
seven roughly so plus two is okay
but there's a problem okay you have a
think about this right we've been
solving algebraically but I always tell
you with things like this and especially
with inequalities involved you should
always try to graph okay so you can
craft this you guys this guy and you
grab this guy and you look for their
point of intersection because that's
what saw me summers for Dutch you
realize something's gone wrong because
it looks like this x12 looks like just a
regular on straight line okay this guy
here has some domain restrictions and
you can go check it out and you'll see
that what it does is this it goes off
like that and then
like that it is a it's an even function
okay perfect square what's going wrong
how many solutions are there to this
there is one namely x equals two so why
would we think that negative 2 is a
solution why do we think it we added a
solution same problem is before right
that makes sense i squared that added
another solution okay and that's a bad
idea
now hold on a call in a second we were
careful we check domain we've got
restrictions why didn't the restrictions
pick it up tell you square root what
that what would be okay so you mean you
mean testing it okay yeah I see all
right
okay there we go right now here's the
idea this is correct to say another way
with mr. restriction in mr. restriction
we were so caught up with the square
root side right that we forgot that this
guy also has a restriction on hmm did
you catch it underneath the square root
it's very positive that's why we get
that okay but that also implies that the
whole square root right whatever result
you get after you plug it over in there
the whole thing on this left-hand side
should be positive right this number
could never be negative so that means X
1/2 must always be itself positive right
because I'm saying excellent ood is
equal to some positive number so X on
the suit must be greater than or equal
to 0 right so therefore X has to be
greater than or equal to 0 okay that
makes sense we missed the restriction so
this means not only is this true
actually this is boilers it's actually
incorrect right X can't be less than
that because they are stay positive
that's why this solution here
doesn't work okay and that's why the
graph now let me do one more thing and
show you show you why why did we get two
solutions solving this and solving this
a totally different okay I can prove it
to you I'll prove to you the same way I
prove those problem what I do here was I
graphed right to show you look at only
intersects months right
well this second line new what does it
look like the left-hand side is another
graph and the right-hand side is a graph
like what kind of graphs are they x
squared minus three is a parabola like
sir an x squared or four is also problem
right namely something like this I guess
it's fat off and it goes to the origin
so these are two solutions plus or minus
two okay so what I'm trying to get
across to you squaring both sides
fundamentally changes the kind of
question you're dealing with okay and
that's why adds extra solutions okay
so don't do it use auxiliary angle or
use T results but don't use this
identity map